festejen uruguayos festejen que la
victoria es de ustedes en octubre de
tabaré vázquez consiguió su primera
victoria en las elecciones
presidenciales y se dirigía de esta
forma a la multitud que lo ovacionaba en
montevideo con su victoria la izquierda
llegó por primera vez al poder en la
historia de uruguay en 2015 vázquez
alcanzaría de nuevo la presidencia del
país y creo que hay frente amplio- para
rato muchas generaciones más si sigue
así creo que el hueso muy inteligente y
mi nieto lo van a ver también gobiernos
progresistas la mañana de este domingo 6
de diciembre
uruguay se ha despertado con la triste
noticia de la muerte de tabaré vázquez
de 80 años a causa de un cáncer de
pulmón detectado en agosto de 2019 el ex
presidente se crió en el humilde barrio
de la teja en montevideo desde donde
llegó a la universidad para
especializarse en oncología en 1989 ganó
las elecciones a la intendencia de
montevideo y se convirtió en el primer
gobernante de la historia de la
coalición de izquierda frente amplio
con profundo dolor comunicamos el
fallecimiento de nuestro presidente de
honor
tabaré vázquez su ejemplo de integridad
política y compromiso inquebrantable con
nuestro país y la gente nos impulsará a
continuar su legado tras 2004 su
presidencia estuvo marcada por su
preocupación por la salud y la lucha
contra la industria tabacalera en el
recuerdo que era el litigio con la
poderosa multinacional philip morris su
veto en 2008 a la despenalización del
aborto y él celebra caso del ex militar
josé gavazzo de presunto ocultamiento de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
durante la dictadura de 1973 a 1985
quedan como principal sombra de sus dos
mandatos presidenciales además de la
política y sus dos grandes pasiones
fueron el fútbol y la medicina y será
recordado como el político que llevó a
la izquierda al poder por primera vez en
la pequeña nación suramericana